most comedians are quick to compliment
Joe Rogan oh man Jo dick huge but these
are the top three times he got roasted
by Comics starting off with Bill bur you
had to beat the [__] out of people for
like three decades before you could like
chill smoke a little weed put on your
Little Rascal's hat and just chill out
coming in at number two is Mark Norman
with a Zinger on protect our Parks the
building's blown outward like it's blown
out now I'm obviously not a [__] bomb
expert but I talked to one
correct he can't stop himself and the
funniest moment on this list comes to us
from Theo's most recent appearance on
JRE I used to have piranhas yeah of
course you did man who doesn't think you
did